starting a car company is crazy you're
going to lose all your money i was like
i think i probably will lose all my
money i agree
the world is so complex today it's
really hard to invent something if
you're
if you're not an expert education is
essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they
have available want to be happy build a
life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level of genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from elon musk jeff bezos
and other
billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one believe in yourself with elon
musk
we really tried hard to convince a lot
of companies
honestly i was in so many panels
but they generally were yeah generally
the settlement that was expressed that
you mentioned earlier that was pretty
much universal
um especially uh if back in
say 2008 or 2007 like when we first
unveiled the roads from 2007
um yeah i mean it was just basically
they just said well you're basically a
bunch of fools well
i mean generally they say like well who
starting a car company is crazy
you're going to lose all your money i
was like i think i probably will lose
all my money i agree
it wasn't like i thought it would be
successful i thought we had maybe a 10
chance of success so then people would
say you're it's going to fail and you're
going to lose
lose everything it's like yeah probably
true yeah
what else is new lesson number two
combine expertise and the beginner's
mind with jeff bezos
you need people who and this is very
tricky
you need people who are experts
in a certain domain area because the
world is so complex today it's really
hard to invent something if you're
if you're not an expert if you don't
have the underlying tools
at your disposal and and know what's
going on you can't you know invent
something in
neurosurgery without knowing something
about neurosurgery
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very advanced and that's
true in every
every field of endeavor but to really be
an inventor
you have to combine that expertise with
the beginner's mind
you have to have a certain child-like
ability
to not be trapped by your expertise
and that fresh look that beginner's mind
once you're an expert
is unbelievably hard to maintain but
great inventors
are always looking they have a certain
divine discontent and they they may have
seen something a thousand times and
still
it occurs to them that that thing even
though they're accustomed to it
could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and i also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure
you know willingness to fail is critical
for invention willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
you know most inventions don't really
work that well in the beginning
they're clumsy they're little toddlers
they're always falling and tripping
and so you have to have a a a culture in
your organization that supports this
kind of
stumbling and wandering you know you
want just because you're wandering
doesn't mean you're lost
and that's a really important thing to
keep in mind when you're
trying to invent lesson number three
understand what
counts with bill gates education is
essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they
have available uh you know i took
these numbers won't make any sense
anymore but the hardest freshman math
class was called math 55
uh i assume it's not called that anymore
but it was it was a group of
uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math
that they had ever met so there were 79
frauds
uh one person who really was the
the best at math i ended up the guy who
came in first in the class is a lawyer
in new york now
uh the guy who came in second as a
professor of chaos theory of uh
princeton uh and then i came in third uh
so i knew okay math geez uh that's
interesting
anyway uh
i didn't take physics uh 55
but i read the feynman book and so if
you're motivated
seriously you don't have to take a
course the feynman book if you're
hardcore
just read the finding book do the
problems you want to learn
to do software read the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but you know anyone that's rated 30 or
harder
is like super hard to do and so
a mooc in a sense doesn't change what
counts uh you know it's always been in
the textbook
but the percentage of students who just
buy textbooks and
and read them and know the subject is
vanishingly small
you kind of have to have this thing
where a bunch of kids all come at the
same time
uh and you know if you don't study
you're going to get a bad grade and your
parents may not like that
you have to create all these social
things in order for people to get into
this mode of
hyper concentrating and actually
understanding
why should i concentrate you know if i'm
a high school student they put x's and
y's up on the board
how does that relate to my life now if
you understood that being good at math
lets you get a good job travel the world
uh you might say okay it does relate to
me but that's a
very indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that uh to concentrate
that's what's missing and so moocs
to the degree that it's easier to take a
mooc than it is to read a textbook yeah
that's nice it's a little bit
interactive there's a video
that's partly why i like the learning
company like all their economics there's
a guy in timothy taylor who has
five courses on economics i super
recommend uh
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
engage in that learning and how do you
create the environment
and the sense of achievement and the
sense of capability
that sitting in there and you know
looking at x's and y's and manipulating
them
uh seems like a smart thing to do lesson
number four
simplify and commit with grant cardone
the idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first
i got to read the instruction first like
nobody really does read this
i never read the answer i wrote an
article about it i don't read any
instructions you know
and so i mean i can't even i can't read
them because they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler
yeah so and that is the premise there
yeah
can't it just be simpler yeah and and
the way to make it simple is and
we see this happening today i mean this
is happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple pick me
up
it's crazy i don't have to put the
address in it should locate where i
am car picks me up i put in the
destination tells guy where to go
you don't even need to pay for it either
it's already i don't have to sit up like
simple you guys got
everything should be simplified and the
way to simplify things i remember
mercedes ben years ago i heard about
this when they had first
figured out how to put a drop back a
hard top uh convertible
into the trunk they had never they
couldn't figure it out it used to be
these old
you know they'd hang them up in the
garage and take them off and it was like
very laborious
and somebody at mercedes-benz said don't
tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done just get it done
no matter what
this is how the elon musk are thinking
today you know this is why apple keeps
creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say
get rid of the phone yeah and i still
want to communicate
yeah and it'll probably be on a headset
more like this we'll probably we'll
probably go in here right where i'm
popping i mean
the watches yeah they're they're moving
there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call blah blah blah
we're moving in that direction of less
and faster and simpler so the way the
human being does that he's in brisbane
that's part of the gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he
he just gets a flight no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you don't know
if you know about this last night you'd
have been you'd have been doing work
about it last night planning negotiating
with the airlines
when you get compressed on time and you
got a commitment you're like i got to be
there at 2 30.
everything works out yeah as i was
walking out my assistant she goes oh
where where are you going to stay
and i was like book me a place we're
close to you know
to the park or where you're staying you
won't put that out but um
we're on this trip we went to tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees
so there's got to be some planning
there's got to be is it stretched over
it doesn't need to be me doing the
planning though
yeah like i think maybe i need somebody
else to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with
success resources to come here and do
these events good tell me when the
events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i call
him a pilot
i want to let route to sydney but let's
stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai uh kids have never
been there we'll stay there for three
days acclimate for a second and
down to sydney i had enough data to know
that i would need to do a route like
that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and uh lanny said hey we might want to
be careful with this storm coming down
there
i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone okay in our path
he's like grant we can't go that way
we'd have to go all the way around this
storm i said no we don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo
i would have never done that but i was
committed to going to sydney
and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer
to where you're going to go hey man
everybody how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five silence the voices with
jamie curran lima
i think when dreams start to brew in us
or when there's like a seed planted in
us where we have this dream
it kind of started that way where i was
like like it was like a little inkling
like
wait a minute if i if i could figure out
how to
launch it how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people
and then i would kind of like silence
that dream and i would my head would
take over
oh jamie you have no connections you
have barely any money you don't know
anything about the beauty industry and
you're you're in your dream job right
now
right and so it was i went through that
battle and i think everyone listening to
us right now
probably like really if they get still
they probably know right now
if there's a dream on their heart or or
something they
know what they're supposed to create or
go after or offer the world or start
painting again or start dancing
right they kind of know um but sometimes
our head talks ourselves out of our
lives absolutely dreams
lesson number six redefine failure with
sarah bligley
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother
and me to fail so at the dinner table he
would actually ask us what did you fail
at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go
and high-five me and what
it was such a gift what he was doing i
didn't realize that at the time but he
was
redefining failure for me and so failure
became not about the outcome but about
not trying and so you know the fear of
failure as we all know as entrepreneurs
is one of the greatest fears in life
it's one of the things that stops us in
our tracks and keeps us from trying
something
um and so i you know i incorporate that
in my
philosophy at spanx we have we celebrate
failures we talk about them we have oops
meetings where i'll announce the oops
that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach theme
songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to
try to get the people that you work with
to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not
safe if i make mistakes and lesson
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is be different with mark cuban you
talked about
companies having a unique advantage can
you speak more on that for me please
sure i mean
what is it that that a customer can get
from you
that they can't get from anybody else
and you have to be very careful with
that too when i just talked about lying
to yourself as an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber
but it has pink cars uber doesn't have
pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature
pink uber cars that's a feature that's
not a unique product
excuse me so you have to know what it is
that you do
that is so unique people's the people
your potential customers say whoa
i did not know that as opposed to well
i'm gonna go tell uber
that they should probably add pink cars
because
whenever you're competing with them you
know all of you are going to compete
with amazon at some point
if you're not already just the reality
and so you've got to understand when
amazon starts looking at my customer
base
what is it that i can convey to them
that makes me unique
and that's that's what i meant by unique
difference now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i have seen
people and it it happens to everybody no
matter what it is
i've seen people rip you apart on both
sides
for both how how does that
what what what how does that drive you
does that drive you at all does that
does that one political correctness of
having to conform and being
what everybody says you're supposed to
be
does that drive you at all well it's
it's
uh you try you try to ignore you try to
ignore it to some extent you know
you try um not to um but you don't
you know you don't try to um you don't
try to put yourself
into any of these um very uncomfortable
straight jackets
and you know you don't want um and i
think that's
that's what's so uh pernicious about all
the identity politics that uh
that um you know we we all have to be
in in this category we're all the same i
think people are all different we're all
you know we're all we're all you know
i'm somewhat idiosyncratic but i think
all of us
are all of us are idiosyncratic in
different ways and i think
i think this is a this is something that
um most people experience that they're
being put into
boxes way more than they're comfortable
you know there's this interview question
i always like asking people
tell me something that's true that very
few people agree with you on
and um it's a very hard question to
answer
um and it's it's not because people
don't have answers they actually have
lots of answers to it
it's because they're uncomfortable
answering it in the context of an
interview
because um you know if it has the answer
has to be something the person
asking you won't agree and we're always
nervous about doing that
we always want to fit in and this uh
this this pressure to fit in
is uh is really powerful
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you should just
be yourself right i mean i take pride in
the fact that i didn't give
what anybody thought or said i was just
going to be myself i find if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm quite grumpy